I know I've technically done the first
story of the first doctor already but in
many ways this one is ground zero
[Music]
the Daleks so classic who review time
because it's Sunday and every Sunday we
view new Doctor Who and at least once a
month they do a classic Doctor Who story
so this time I am talking about the
Daleks which is what we call it now at
the time it was seven episodes each with
individual names because that was how
they did those initial episodes for
Doctor Who it was only later they
started calling it you know under a
single title of part 1 part 2 part 3 so
on so yes this is the doctor's first
ever trip to Skaro his first encounter
with the Daleks and it is an interesting
thing to go back and watch and I think I
I often try I know some viewers feel I
don't succeed in this but I haven't
tried to be fair to classic Doctor Who
when looking at it and reviewing it and
trying to think of how it holds up for
something of the time I try not to be
overly harsh on on elements that are
issues to me as someone watching it from
now much later but at the same time that
does tend to seep in because that's my
perspective I can't J I can only flight
force myself to a different perspective
so far but this one I I'm trying
probably harder than as usual I had to
kind of scrub from my brain everything I
know about the Daleks from later on so
all the things you know all kinds of
inconsistencies or little things that
they dropped you know almost immediately
just for example things like the fact
that they have to move on a metal floor
because they absorb static electricity
that's have the tanks are powered like
those sorts of things not even really
gonna dwell on because yeah that got
changed quickly because it was limiting
and they realized oh we need to do more
with these and they moved on and I think
this one possibly more than any of
so you need to try and set your mind
back to what it would have been like to
see this for the first time which I
don't think you necessarily have to do
with a lot of with as many other old
stories certainly not a lot of the most
classic whose stories were one offs one
off you know aliens a one off planet
that we're not gonna see again
so yeah and then for all intents and
purposes that's what this was at the
time they aired it so - see - imagine
seeing this for the first time it's
pretty impressive in a lot of ways first
of all I mean let's really take a second
to admire the design on the Daleks it's
easy to make fun of now you know this
little sort of rolling trashcan is
something that I would refer to them as
when I felt like mocking them you know
the in Britain they call the Pepper
Potts a lot you know it's it's an easy
thing to make fun of now but think about
how alien that thing actually is its
shape its size its configuration nothing
about that reads as something a human
would have put together that adds to the
alienness and because it is mechanical
because it's the tank that is the only
thing we see we do get the implication
of the mutant inside but we don't see it
and really that avoids the floppy rubber
suit which was the big fall down of most
aliens in 60 sci-fi shows you make
something look that looks hard and metal
you can do it much better and they took
advantage of that and honestly not even
let's even the suckers aren't
particularly laughable in this it's used
to like hold it in against a wall
it feels powerful at one point it's it's
a really impressive piece of design all
things considered and trying to imagine
seeing that for the first time yeah I
get why people were fascinated or
possibly terrified by them because of
just the strangeness of this
of this thing and you know again at this
point I've been living with this design
for a long time but to try and think
back yeah and that must be weird seeing
you for the first time there's also
obviously a lot of sort of interesting
things in terms of the diamond name
Diamond Amex oh my god
the dynamics of the doctor himself he's
this is only the second story with him
so he is it's not it's more than just
him being grumpy he's very undocked ER
at times he he deliberately deceives his
companions and I was gonna say knowingly
puts them in danger he he doesn't
necessarily know how dangerous the
situation is but he absolutely goes
against what all three of them want by
faking that they can't take the TARDIS
back off just so he can go and look at
this city there's the prioritization of
his scientific nature and his humanity
is a background feature it's actually a
long time before it comes out even after
they've escaped to the Daleks initially
he wants to just go right then and the
only reason they don't is because they
have to go back to the city to get the
fluid link again and at one point he
even says the Thals are not our
responsibility that they're not our
problem and knowing what the Daleks were
like and that the Thals were in danger
from their very presence I was cold of
course again the doctor didn't know the
extent of his danger so he's not totally
devoid of empathy but it basically takes
him realizing that the Daleks are going
to Arabia the entire planet and kill
everything that isn't them before he
actually steps up and sort of feels any
kind of moral obligation towards helping
to stop them but that's like second to
last episode that it takes a while for
him to get there it's kind of
interesting to watch that because we're
used to regardless of anything else
about the doctor we're very used to him
being oh there's a problem here here let
me solve it here he doesn't care he
cares about knowledge he cares about
information then he cares about getting
out of
and it's it's interesting to go back and
watch and it's a good performance but
yeah if you're used to modern Doctor Who
that's jarring because he's the doctor
himself is not particularly heroic in
this one I would say even less so than
he was in the first one very much Ian is
framed as the hero although then we get
into this and this is in this is kind of
where my modern perspective is gonna
seep into things like I'll try and go
back in time you know thinking of things
like the Daleks but then I look at
someone like Ian and go you're kind of a
tool to the extent like I get that his
archetype and as a character he is the
kind of a stand back while I do this
kind of guy but the degree of it here is
ridiculous like he's he's had his legs
paralyzed by the Daleks and somebody you
know one of them is gonna be released by
his Daleks to go out and get something
he'd come back and Susan is the most
able-bodied at that point everyone's
stricken with radiation poisoning she's
the one affected the least it's a door
thing she volunteers to do it but he
instead like no it must be me like oh
for God's sake man although at the same
time it's hard to blame him too much
because okay I talked about the doctors
depiction of being chauvinistic as being
overdone in twice upon a time and I
still hold by that what I feel like is
when Moffat wrote that he set the doctor
as a character about as chauvinistic as
the show as a whole could sometimes be
in its early runs because not only do we
have you know Barbara frequently on the
verge of fainting Susan oh my god
I feel like Susan is a beloved character
by association with that brilliant
speech that the doctor gives at the end
of Dalek invasion of Earth because her
depictions so far and the stories I've
seen her in outside of that one even
that one I need to revisit
she just screams a lot like a lot of law
like even when like she's going outside
to get the stuff like I said she
volunteered for this job but she's
running through the Petrified Forest
she's not running from anything she's
just she's traveling from point A to
point B and she can't do it with that oh
my god and then there's more than a few
very mocking ha ha ha silly female
things with the Thals not towards Susan
and Barbara but towards their own you
know fellow Thal who happens to be a
woman so and again I don't want to
overstate this and Molly this show is
super chauvinistic it's misogynistic
about like it's not but it's of its time
in terms of the depictions of characters
like Barbara and Susan's especially Ian
I think the doctor is actually the one
who feels like the the biggest exception
to that dynamic just because he's cranky
doesn't like anybody so it's it's at
least more consistent and not overly
focused on one's gender it's now since I
brought up the Thals
they are another bit of an iffy point on
this I've mentioned in some other times
that one of the strengths of classic
Doctor Who was getting to spend more
time with the supporting cast in these
new locations and getting to know them
better and the case of the Falls though
it just feels safe they kind of
rubber-stamped out a bunch of repeats of
the same bad or know two or three
characters and it doesn't help that they
all look really similar they're almost
identically costumed pretty much all of
them are blond like it it gets really
hard to distinguish some of these guys
and they're not especially interesting
although that wouldn't have been such a
problem except I think this entire story
is stretched it's padded by oh probably
about two episodes so like after they
escape the city and they realize we have
to go back there
that is a nice raising of tension like
what we get oh my god we have to go back
but then the amount of time it takes for
them to get back and like there's
actually an episode called the ordeal
and it feels like an ordeal to watch it
because it's just watching these you
know Ian and and these Falls
you know crawling through this cave and
like why are we being dragged along for
this part of it like tell us the route
you're going to take so that we
understand how you get there and just
get there like at the very least one of
these should have been cut and it should
have only been six episodes possibly I
think they could have gotten away with
five now you know what we'll go with six
because five they they still get the
sort of talking the Thals into into sort
of taking up arms which is I think one
of the more balanced sort of discussions
that happens because Ian you know does
sort of have the whole he believes that
they should fight but he also doesn't
want to force them to do what's good for
them he's like they must decide to fight
for themselves and you know again it's a
very sort of generically heroic
sentiment and I kind of like them
Barbara calls him out a little bit like
that's you just you're just mixing and
matching words you're still after the
same thing we're after I kind of like
that she calls him out on that and the
show wasn't structured in a way to say
that she's wrong for calling him out on
that it doesn't necessarily say she's
right but given how in balance some of
the depiction of barbara susan versus
ian is i it felt nice it felt a nice
presentation of here's the situation
here's this one guy's perspective here's
someone calling him out and be like come
on dude really and I think that works
pretty well
coming back to the dogs themselves cuz I
mainly just talked about the design I
like them here for a lot of reasons and
this is a good balance of the scheming
and the extermination minded because
unfortunately as time would go on that
kind of just became shouty stormtroopers
you know exterminate exterminate
exterminate like and we
wouldn't have context as to why
and I'd like I know that sounds weird
like why are the Daleks need context
they just kind of want to be surname
everything and that's that's true but
I'm like the we get a little into the
thought process of the Daleks and it
doesn't make them more sympathetic it
actually kind of makes them scarier
because you realize the reason at least
at this point in this story that they
want to exterminate everything is
because that's how they live zero regard
for damage to anything else complete and
total self-serving self-centeredness our
race is the only thing that matters if
everything else dies fine let's do it
right now and it is it is kind of scary
the single-mindedness of it but we do
get a balance between that that desire
and that's seeking to just tear
everything down that isn't them and that
does get called out as well sort of the
other nests that with which they view
the thousand while they will never care
about them and but at the same time
there is more underhandedness at play
they are playing some of these
characters a little bit we get to see
them scheme where it isn't just one of
them shouting orders at another and that
is an element of the dog that I think
has largely been lost over time both in
new and classic who for the most part
when the dollars show up they're just
there to be the force of danger and of
evil there isn't a lot of nuance to to
their planning and what they're up to
not that I'm saying there should be
nuance to them as characters like is
that probably not but there could be
more nuance to how they operate and that
has kind of been lost over time but it's
more on display here and pretty well
balanced so yeah I think I'm not sure I
have too much more to say this one might
end up shorter than I would usually go I
don't feel like sort of picking through
you know each individual thing going on
I hit most of the major things that I
wanted to talk about Oh one random like
little thing just awesome touch first
episode there at the city
and Barbara is wandering through the
halls and the doors closed behind her
not a sound totally 100% silent no Shh
no coupe when the when it hits the floor
total silence just and the doors closed
that was eerie
that was eerie as hell that was great
like can we get back to the sort of the
silent Menace of the Daleks because I
feel like that that should be a thing
we've gotten again over obsessed with
the like oh let's have them run silent
for a little bit I think I think we can
really ramp up the creep factor in a
story if they play with that again so
yeah that's the Daleks it it is a
landmark episode but because it is so
early you do see a lot of some of the
growing pains of the show and some of
the characters as a whole in terms of
pacing and characterizations and things
like that but no it still holds up for
the most part and you can definitely see
why it helped boost the profile of this
show you immediately get why people
latched on to these creatures right away
because they are unique and really
effective as villains and really
unsettling so the Daleks have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it I'm
trying to cut down and not go through
the entire meal of stuff I have I've got
links for all this stuff that you know
what to do is all down in the
description
the big ones patreon I'll still single
that one out but other than that check
out the stuff in the description if you
care so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]